one of the true expressions of
testosterone and trying to really
express your ability and your combative
ability now in the in the modern world
is power and influence so in the olden
days you'd go to war you come back with
a ribbon nowadays you've got x amount of
followers you can move the world with
money I can bend reality with money
please understand if I walk into Jimmy
Choo they lock the door no broke he's
allowed in Tate's here and I buy
whatever the [ __ ] I want there's lines
outside because I'm there I bend the
world with money that's how I that's how
the wars are now won so you're talking
about high status males and that it's
always been that way now you have a
whole contingent of men who aren't dead
okay they didn't die in a ditch but
they're loneliest [ __ ] jerking off and
that's the reality of it and and women
don't give a [ __ ] about them and why
should you I'm all sitting here actually
[ __ ] on women in any way I think
women have a biological instinct to a
degree to try and find the best mate
they can because it gives them the
highest chance of survival and the harsh
realities of the world and if they look
at a man who's not capable they just
don't feel an attraction to him and
that's the bottom line of it